you
for me there were two photographers just
two photographers irving penn and
Richard Avedon and if you know I talk
about music lineage i guess if there was
lineage i come from that school not the
cartier bresson school not the DNR bird
school although we all experiment when
we're coming up and I had my you know I
did run around Paris with my leica being
cart a brace on and I did you know knock
on the door of a gypsy family and be
Diane Arbus or Diane Arbus so we go
through our stages but I was always
interested in the blank canvas and I
learned that the blank canvas existed
through Penn & Avedon and they had very
different energies and I never got to
meet either one of them or photograph
them but that's kind of their their work
is just again indelible
I studied with philippe halsman he was a
great life magazine photographer and it
was his edict that a photograph isn't
successful and unless you captured the
subjects in her life so I heard that you
know before I was 20 and that still
resonates for me so if you can't if you
don't know who someone is by looking at
the picture that I've taken then I
haven't succeeded so in terms of
greatness of photography I think that
extends to everybody's work you know you
want to you want to believe the moment I
mean there are rotten ads and there are
great ads in the commercial world I mean
that Louis Vuitton campaign it's brit
it's brilliant and then there are other
ones that i just want to roll my eyes
and say are they kidding you know that
you take someone very famous in a dolce
gabbana add who is past the age that she
should be for this ad you know with fake
cleavage and a cat that looks miserable
and it's not working for me you know and
then you turn the page and there's a
guest jeans ad that's so working and
it's just singing off the page because
it's real and because the energy is all
there and all the elements come together
in the right way